today on the matt walsh show joe biden
officially announces a 300 billion
dollar vote buying scheme with his
student loan forgiveness plan and yet
the administration has not been able to
defend this morally and financially
catastrophic policy we'll discuss also
ron desantis provokes more outrage with
his comments about dr fauci a woman sues
her psychiatrist for signing off on a
gender transition after just one meeting
with him george foreman is accused of
sexual assault 50 years ago is there no
statute of limitations on accusations
like this should there be and our daily
cancellation we'll deal with social
media influencers who use their children
for clout all of that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
the best thing you can do right now is
to put yourself into a better financial
situation dig into your expenses your
savings your investments take action to
cut back where you can if you have a lot
of credit card debt or high living
expenses deal with it right now call
american financing for a free no
obligation mortgage review and learn how
your home can work for you i mean you've
probably put a lot of time and effort
into it and many of you may be
experiencing significant equity gains it
may be time to access that equity as
cash put it towards credit card interest
or any high interest debt for that
matter you can learn more about custom
options and you really got to look into
these options right now because we're
all looking for ways to spend money uh
rather we're looking for ways to save
money maybe spend it too by calling
american financing there's no pressure
no upfront or hidden fees it's worth 10
minutes of your time to learn more
that's all it will take no reason not to
take advantage of it all you got to do
is call this number 866 569-4711
that again is
or
866-569-4711
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
joe biden's first and last term in
office has been an unmitigated disaster
in every sense of the term across the
entire board and in every area though
biden is likely not aware of his
failures because he's not aware of
anything he doesn't even know how he got
into whatever room he's standing in
currently
much less much less does he understand
his own policies or their impact on the
public still
it has been a cavalcade of catastrophes
so
what else is a democrat
going to do heading into an election
season with no achievements to highlight
no successes to brag about well he has
only one desperation move one he'll
marry play and that is to of course
bribe the voters or rather
more specifically bribe some of the
voters a relatively small fraction
actually and to do so at the expense of
all the other voters hoping that the
group left holding the bag doesn't
notice that they're holding it
and so finally yesterday after much
buildup in anticipation president biden
did officially announce that he would
forgive quote unquote 300 billion
dollars of student loan debt the plan
which the white house unveiled on
wednesday would wipe out ten thousand
dollars worth of loans for
borrowers earning less than 125 000 in
income as individuals or 250 000 as a
household
he has taken out his magic wand and
poofed all of that debt away well not
really i mean the wand is more of a
giant broom which will be used to sweep
the debt from one part of the room over
into another even larger part
the mess that had been mucking up one
corner will now become a more widely
distributed mess across a larger portion
of the house and worst of all the people
that are now left to deal with the mess
are precisely the ones who did not
create it and had nothing at all to do
with it
the plan translates into about two
thousand dollars worth of additional
financial burden for every taxpayer but
that's only the beginning the even
greater cost will come in the form of
inflation of course biden says that
there's no need to worry about inflation
because reasons
by resuming student loan payments at the
same time as we provide targeted relief
we're taking an economically responsible
course
as a consequence
about 50 billion dollars a year will
start coming back into the treasury
because the resumption of debt
independent experts agree that these
actions taken together
will provide real benefits for families
without meaningful effect on inflation
well that is nonsense obviously as uh
jason furman a former economic advisor
to obama wrote yesterday he said pouring
roughly half a trillion dollars of
gasoline on the inflationary fire that's
already burning is reckless doing it
while going well beyond one campaign
promise ten thousand student loan relief
and breaking another all proposals paid
for is even worse
now that's especially compelling coming
from an economics guy who worked for a
democrat but we don't need him or anyone
else to tell us this obviously dumping
300 billion dollars into an economy
already ravaged by inflation will create
more inflation any rational person can
see that
even as the democrats as always tell us
not to believe our lying eyes and also
don't believe our lying ears
especially when our ears heard nancy
pelosi just recently declare that the
president does not have the authority to
do what he just did yesterday you may
recall this
people think that the president of the
united states
is this more on the subject and you ever
want to know will you let me know people
think that the president of the united
states has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone
he can delay
but he does not have that power that
would has to be an act of congress
yet another moment to be shoved down the
memory hole
but if you really want to understand how
indefensible this move from biden is all
you have to do is listen to the
administration
try to defend it
for example here was biden yesterday
when asked whether this policy is fair
to the people who've already paid back
their loans
that's a very good question here's what
he says
thank you mr president is this unfair to
people who paid their student loans or
chose not to take out loans
is it fair to people who in fact
do not own multi-billion dollar
businesses they've seen what these guys
give them all attachments is that fair
what do you think
what about people who paid their loans
so struggle to pay their loans and now
others don't have to
what
what that was a total non-sequitur
too incoherent and irrelevant to even
qualify as a straw man mr president um
why did you just kick that dog in the
face
why did i kick the dog well
what about the orca and free willy
remember him he was treated poorly
was that fair was it
what
and before you blame his response on
dementia please note how the white house
spokesperson um was also asked some
questions about this and didn't perform
much better when confronted with a
similar line of questioning let's watch
that
again here's what we have done here's
what here's about how much it might cost
it might not cost who is paying for this
what we are saying is the the work that
this administration has done the work
that the democrats in congress has done
is actually there and you see that the
1.7 trillion
deficit in deficit deduction that you
see is is going to benefit us in being
able to do something for the middle
class to do something for the middle
class
this is about doing something for people
who make less than 125 000
1.7 trillion
that's what we've been able to do but
when you forgive
debt you're not just disappearing debt
so who is paying for what
and then i'll give you the second part
we lifted the pause right we're going to
lift the pause uh at the end of this
year which is going to matter right
which is going to offset a lot of what
what we're doing as well
well that doesn't answer the question at
all and it's nonsense first of all think
about what they're claiming here the
white house expects us to believe that
they're offsetting the 300 billion loan
forgiveness by not forgiving the rest of
it
what
if i lend you 20 and then i forgive half
of it can i offset the cost of losing 10
of the dollars on mode by still
recouping the other 10
now i'm not a math wiz but that doesn't
seem to make a lot of sense to me but of
course my analogy doesn't really work
because in that scenario um i am eating
the cost of my own forgiveness
because by the way that's what
forgiveness actually is when you forgive
someone that's something that you are
choosing to do
okay you are to use the favorite leftist
phrase you are doing the work
but if you're um
just making someone else
carry the burden
then that's not forgiveness
and in this case though karen gene pair
doesn't want to say it out loud the
people paying for this forgiveness are
the ordinary taxpayers
and as always the burden will be will be
felt heaviest most by the working class
so think about this plan for a moment
college graduates earning six figures as
an individual
will have part of their debts paid by
people making a fraction of their salary
most of whom didn't even go to college
and i know that because the majority of
adults in this country do not have
bachelor degrees
the median individual income in the usa
is less than forty thousand dollars
biden is offering forgiveness quote
unquote to college graduates making
three times the median
half of the student debt is held by
graduate students graduate students are
in fact
you know a big part of the reason why
we're in this mess again half of the
debt is theirs
and these are people who kept taking out
loans they didn't just take out loans
when they were 18 but when they were
well into adulthood kept taking out
loans staying in school for years and
years
we all know people like this it's just
like they don't want to get a job or
live so they just keep going back to
school racking up degree after worthless
degree staying there for years spending
all this money and now those who made
more responsible decisions and who earn
far less money must carry the burden for
the poor choices they had nothing to do
with that were made by people wealthier
than them
it is obscene
we are in fact bailing out phds by
reaching into the pockets of plumbers
and mechanics
we're taking money from working families
and handing it to gender studies majors
that's what we're doing
words can hardly express
what a ludicrous injustice this actually
is
meanwhile adding insult to injury
nothing at all is being done
to actually solve the underlying problem
or hold any of the guilty parties
accountable
let's start with the universities
it is amazing that we can constantly
have this conversation about student
debt
the student debt crisis and yet the
universities are led off the hook
completely
it's like they when when we talk about
student debt it's like the universities
don't even exist where's this debt
coming from what are the people paying
for
what why why are they taking out the
loans
to go to the universities
why are the loans so much money because
the universities are charging that much
why are they charging that much no one
even asks the question especially on the
left they don't
why the hell should it cost
a hundred thousand dollars to go one of
these stupid places
they're not made to justify those those
prices they never are
when's the last time you saw any
university official uh being asked by
anyone hey
why are you guys charging this much
what about there you know let's look at
the salaries we hear so much about the
you know dreaded
millionaires and billionaires in the
corporate world
what about the salaries of these these
university officials administrative
officials
the universities are still charging
exorbitant fees for an education that
proves to be worthless most of the time
in fact now they can charge even more
and they could be even more reckless
knowing that the federal government will
come in and transfer the debt from the
borrower to his neighbor across the
street
so the corruption and greed in the
university system is not only not
addressed but actually encouraged
also the school system before you get to
the university system you have the
school system grade schools
funneling millions of kids into the
universities
they're still doing this
they were doing this when i went to
grade school
that's not subtle they're like telling
you you need to go to college you don't
go to college you're gonna be a failure
you're not gonna be able to make any
money
that's what they tell kids
any accountability there
what about the employers
who are still doing their part to deepen
the crisis by requiring college degrees
for positions that don't necessitate
them and for jobs that must be learned
by doing whether you have a degree or
not now there are exceptions to this but
most jobs out there in the world most of
them
you learn them just by doing them you
don't learn them by going to school for
four years you go to school for 20 years
and you're not going to be
even even a fraction of the way there in
terms of like being ready for most jobs
that exist because you have to actually
do it and get training
these are the culprits constantly
working every day to inflate the student
debt bubble
and not a single thing is being done to
stop them not a single thing
instead the problem is allowed to
persist the cancer is left untreated and
the people made to pay the price are
precisely those people who have the
least to do with any of it
you know what the greatest insult to
injury actually is is that uh
you know go
talk to people that are in college
about why they're there
well most most of the college kids they
have no idea what they want to do with
their lives so it's not that they're
it's not that
no what's one of the main reasons that
kids even go to college it's for the um
it's for the social experience right
i.e in other words they're going to
college because they want to party for
four years
that is a huge part of the motivation
for many of these kids they're taking on
these loans and they're going to college
because they want a party that's what
they do they spend four years party it's
like it's like a vacation like four
years vacation so four years
uh divorced from reality
and now you got working people with real
problems and real things they got to
deal with and families and everything
and they got to pay so that you could
party for four years
now look
you may support
this approach
if you do
it's because you personally benefit
and you don't really care about the
effect it has on other people that's it
i mean it's selfishness
you're allowed to be selfish you know
it's you you can be uh but that's what
it is don't claim it's anything else
but but if you do support it all i ask
is that you please please
never speak another word about equity or
justice or fairness ever again
you have lost the right to pretend to
care about any of those things
so just be honest
it's the least you could do
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
and i know i pointed this out yesterday
but i really i can't quite get over
the other aspect of this the claim being
made here especially given the timing
you know this is happening along with
some of the other issues that we've been
discussing so it just brings you back to
this fact that like according to the
left an 18 year old
cannot consent to a student loan student
loans are predatory because the interest
rates and everything but mainly because
they are being offered
to 18 year olds who don't understand
what they're signing up for so an 18
year old cannot consent to a student
loan which that part i agree with by the
way
it's crazy that we're allowing 18 year
olds to take out loans like this but
that's what the left that part we all
agree left says
can't consent to it
but a 15 year old can consent to a
double mastectomy a 12 year old can
consent to chemical castration a
four-year-old can consent to socially
transitioning to another gender a
four-year-old
can consent to becoming another gender
socially quote unquote
but an 18 year old cannot be expected to
read the terms of a financial agreement
before he signs it
this is what we're expected to
believe these are the ideas we're
expected to take seriously
again it's just obscene is what it is
all right ron desantis has uh made some
people a little bit upset with uh some
remarks that he made
about tony fauci
let's listen to those
you have people like fauci saying that
his lockdowns didn't cause any permanent
damage to any young kids
i got news for you it did and we are
going to reap those rewards across the
whole country for years and years and
years because they treated kids so
poorly and i'm just sick of seeing him i
know he says he's going to retire
someone needs to grab that little elf
and chuck him across the potomac
uh that is really disappointing stuff
honestly um
[Music]
and you know uh you know
how i can be and i i am i'm not a very
sensitive person but
i i have to say it's inappropriate and
unfair um
and again i'm just disappointed
um
deeply unfair to elves to say that
the elves in the lord of the rings are
good they're you know they're also tall
they're honest
they're wise
fouchy's none of those things so this is
just an unfair comparison to elves it's
not it's not fair to call
i would say fauci is more of a
like a gollum type of creature
so what he should have said is pick up
that golem and chuck him across the
potomac now that would have been much
better
just you know fouchy's like this old
shriveled
shifty untrustworthy
obsessed with power
yeah gollum i think is what we so just
in the future let's stop with this let's
stop with the um
the elf slander can we
all right
it's from the new york post says an
australian woman who transitioned to
mail
before realizing it was a mistake is
suing a psychiatrist after he approved
her female to male hormone treatment
following a single meeting
and later signed off on two surgeries to
remove her breasts and uterus
um
jay
langadinos now 31 was just 19 when she
first met dr patrick toohey who's a
veteran sydney psychiatrist in may 2010.
the teen was referred to him by her
endocrinologist to determine if she was
suitable for a gender transition
the specialist wrote that she was very
young and
needed a thorough psychiatric work up
before embarking on hormone treatment
according to a statement of claim
filed
in court after
his first meeting with the teen tsui
concluded
that langadinos suffered from gender
dysphoria and was fit for testosterone
therapy
so this is one meeting the psychiatrist
took one meeting with this individual
and said yep good to go let's get them
on on the hormone therapy and keep in
mind when you hear this story
all of this is 100 typical this is the
way that it goes
because this is how psychiatrists are
programmed now
is they're thinking about drugs
they're going to listen to your talk and
then what drug can we give you
now it's the same thing in many cases if
you want you know if it was you're
looking for anti-depressants just take
one meaning you'll get them
looking for hormone drugs just takes one
meaning
the next time langdinos had an
appointment with tui in february 2012
she told him she was eager to undergo
top surgery to have her breasts
surgically removed as part of her
transition to he approved the double
mastectomy first patient who underwent
the procedure in april of that year
according to the court filing a month
later langadinos met with tui for the
third and final time to discuss removing
her uterus and
once again the psychiatrist said yep go
ahead
so this is three meetings
and we've gotten rid of two body parts
and and we've got drugs first meeting
put them on drugs next meeting take off
the breasts meeting after that
remove the uterus
and the psychiatrist was there signing
off on all this
and then it goes on
detailing how
uh the the langdinos eventually came to
you know relatively quickly came to
regret all of this and now nearly a
decade later language who no longer
identifies as male is suing tui for
professional negligence claiming that he
green lit her hormone therapy even after
she told him that she suffered from
social phobia she also alleges that he
was negligent and not recommending that
she get a second opinion ahead of her
hysterectomy the court filing states
that tui strongly recommended that
lingadinos seek social and family
therapy but she did not heed that
recommendation despite that he went
ahead and signed off on her two
surgeries
so that's that's his apparently that's
his defense is that he said well you
should you should go and seek other
forms of therapy she didn't do it though
and so he but he said well you should
have the drugs anyway
signed off on the drugs and the surgery
this as i said is extraordinarily common
this is not an outlier this is the way
that it works
and even if uh
they extend it to two meetings or three
meetings
i mean there's there's no number of
meetings with a psychiatrist that would
justify a recommendation of removing
healthy body parts
but um the fact is that they don't most
of the time
it only takes a couple
and what's happening here is what needs
to happen all across the world
i mean that is
you know we could talk about how to
fight back against this madness and
there are many ways to do it you know
there's activism there's there's a
political pressure there's all kinds of
things we can do but
um lawsuits
ultimately that's that's what's going to
put a stop to this
and that's the indispensable element of
this uh of this fight is they got to
start suing these people
for negligence
and we're going to see more of this i
mean the class action lawsuits that are
coming down the pike here are just
it's hard to conceive
of what we're going to be looking at
class action lawsuits against
hospitals psychiatrists
uh pharmaceutical industry all of it and
it all needs to happen
all right from the daily wire says
finland's prime minister santa marin who
was already in deep water after video
showing her partying hard with a man not
her husband appeared on social media
apologized on tuesday after a photo
revealed two bare-chested women kissing
at her official residence with one
woman's breasts only covered by a sign
reading finland marin telling reporters
in
helsinki that she had invited some
friends over to sauna swim and spend
time together
after a music festival in july so she's
coming to a so she's attending a music
festival too
this is the prime minister all right
um so the incident occurred in the
downstairs guest bathrooms and said
in my opinion this is what she said in
my opinion that if that photo is not
appropriate i apologize for that that
photo should not be taken
and then i believe she went on
to say once again that she's human
so that's been that's been her excuse
all along
is that well i'm i'm human
yeah we we get that
well that part we understand
but you're also a grown adult and your
prime minister that's
that's the aspect of this that's causing
some problems for people
now the interesting thing is i've
actually seen some people even on the
right um defend this woman and kind of
characterize this as a as cancel culture
oh just let her have fun not hurting
anybody
now we should be very clear about this
that this is not cancel culture
i mean first of all
as the leader of a country it's not
really possible to be a victim of cancer
culture being criticized
is part of the deal and that's that's
supposed to happen
um
you're supposed to be criticized
so there's no amount of criticism or
scrutiny even if it's unfair it's not
that's not cancel culture that just
comes with the territory and it's
necessary and healthy that you be
criticized
and scrutinized all the time
also of course the other thing about
cancer culture is that it is as i'm
always trying to explain it's a it's a
function of of the institutions that's
what canceled culture is
that's what's that's what that's what
differentiates it from other you know
from just holding people accountable or
average everyday sort of run-of-the-mill
criticism it's a function of the
institutions so when you have the
institutions working to punish someone
for something that they've done or said
that's when you have
canceled culture
but when you're running the institutions
because you're the prime minister well
then you can't be victim of no this is a
cancer culture this is um standards of
behavior
which is not cancelled culture and
that's a good thing to have and
especially as conservatives
we that's that's one of the things that
we should be
trying to conserve actually
is
standards of behavior we expect people
to act in a certain way
and our expectations for you are going
to depend on your station in life
depends on who you are what your role is
what what you know what your um vocation
is
if you're an adult in general there are
certain standards of behavior certain
expectations that's good that's that's
one of the things again as conservatives
we should be trying to conserve a
society where there are no expectations
of anyone and you can just do what
anything you want
and without any shame whatsoever
that's what that's what the left wants
that's that's like moral anarchy it's
that's not us that's what they want
so their standards their standards of
behavior if an adult if you're an adult
and then if you're a political leader
even more so
we expect more of you
you should be acting even better than
the average person
because of the responsibilities you've
been given
all right
um
so this is an interesting case that i
just saw right before we went on air
here the new york times it says two
women filed lawsuits in on wednesday in
california alleging that george foreman
who's the former world heavyweight
boxing champion sexually abused them
when they were teenagers in california
in the 1970s according to the lawsuit
the women using their pseudonyms gwen h
and denise s to protect their identities
initially met foreman when they were
under 10 years old through their fathers
one man was a boxer sparring partner of
foreman while the other was a boxing
manager and long time advisor to form it
foreman then groomed the girls for
several years according to the
complaints before forcing them to have
sex with him in places ranging from a
san francisco health hotel to an
apartment in beverly hills the two women
who are both in their early 60s now
filed the complaints in los angeles the
los angeles county superior court
um
representatives for foreman referred
inquiries about the lawsuits to a
statement that he released last month
and he says that this that they're
trying to extort him they've been trying
to extort him for years this is a false
claim and he denies it
now you read this story and you think
are there
of course i i don't know if this
happened or not
um
these are claims dating back 50 years
and so you read that and you think are
there no statute of limitations here how
can you come out 50 years later
now if something did happen to you
when you were much younger when you were
a kid it's it's understandable
that kids who are victimized don't don't
oftentimes don't want to come out right
away because they're
they're they're afraid they've been
intimidated that's part of the
conditioning and the grooming but
like
once you get to it adulthood
at a certain point you have to say if
you if you wait even not just waiting 50
years you've waited like 40 years into
adulthood
and now you're saying something at a
time when it's just impossible to prove
one way or another it would be
impossible to do it's also impossible to
if you've been you know if you're if the
claim is false and you're being falsely
accused it's impossible to vindicate
yourself it's just just a claim
so how can you wait 50 years
should there not be some kind of statute
of limitations putting some urgency on
this saying
if you've been victimized we absolutely
want you to come forward but you can't
wait half a century to come forward
because there's nothing we can do with
the claim at that point
well you would think that but actually
california changed their law
relatively recently they changed it in
response to the metoo hysteria
and according to the law that went into
effect back in 2020
um they extended the statute of
limitations they extended it broadly
just across the board
but then they also basically extended it
indefinitely because now according to
their law
you have
you have to come forward within five
years
if you're if you're claiming you're a
victim you have to come forward within
five years of discovering an injury
so that's the way they've phrased it in
the law
which if you don't think much about it
it sounds like okay well five years
that's okay that's that's not that long
that seems fair
well but they're including psychological
industry uh injury rather so
five years of discovering a
psychological injury
which is another way of saying that you
have forever there is no statute of
limitations
because yeah you could walk into a
psychiatrist's office when you're 65
and say i'm traumatized by something
that happened 50 years ago and that's it
that's all you have to do and now you've
got five years from that first meeting
with a psychiatrist to file a claim
um and it should come as no surprise by
the way that as soon as california put
this uh law on the books or rather it's
amending what you know the currently
existing law as soon as they amended the
law there was there's just been a rush
of claims like this from people
alleging that they were victimized
decades prior
um it's just
obviously total madness
uh
you know you ca it's it there's not an
exact science here as what of what the
statute of limitations should be but i
think any thinking person any rational
person
would agree that 50 years is just way
too long
maybe you know maybe like five years
into adulthood
i think that might make sense
just
you know something between five and
fifty
all right
so we have two stories here of um
hollywood which you know we know
hollywood loves nothing more than
lecturing its own fans
and so we've got two examples of that
one of which i i actually find somewhat
upsetting to me on a personal level so
first this is from variety it says house
of dragon um star house of dragon i
guess that's that's the new game of
thrones show so one of the stars steve
uh tousaint who plays
lord corliss
valaron i don't know
aka the sea snake on the series slammed
viewers of game of thrones prequel who
took issue with his casting um
saying that they're you know that
they're racist
he says it seems to be very hard for
people to swallow he said this in an
interview with men's health
they're happy with a dragon flying
they're happy with white hair and violet
colored eyes but a rich black guy that's
beyond the pale
um
just saying added what has been
wonderful is for every toxic person that
has somehow found their way into my
timeline there have been so many others
who've been so supportive and been like
oh my god i can't wait this is going to
be great
all right and then he goes on from there
so he's accusing viewers of being racist
and he's alleging that they're
criticizing him i guess because he's
portraying a character who in the books
is a white guy and uh in this they
switched him over to a black guy
and so he's calling them all racist for
that criticism
um which to begin with
we could pretty much guarantee that
because we we know this there's a lot of
precedent here
we've seen we've seen many stories like
this
where actors are coming out now it's
very common now like there used to be a
time when when actors would be hesitant
to criticize their own fan base
but now they just love doing it
scolding their own fans and so we know
from president that that often times
when we're told that our fans are racist
because they're criticizing a black
actor and then you look at most of the
criticism you say oh no they're just
they just don't like the performance got
nothing to do with the skin color
but then of course
there's the inconsistency here because
even if there were fans saying that hey
well this
the character here doesn't look like
what he's supposed to look like based on
the books what we know that if you
reverse that
that criticism would be seen as totally
valid
okay we all understand what would happen
if for example a black panther who's a
fictional character
doesn't actually exist so you could make
them look any way you want
but if uh if chris pratt let's just
imagine chris pratt
being uh
cast as for the you know the next black
panther film
there would be
i'm not kidding when i say there would
be riots in the street over that they
would act there would be riots there
would be buildings burning if chris
pratt was given the fictional role of
black panther
and we all kind of understand that
so that criticism is totally valid but
if you do it in the reverse it's
horrifically racist doesn't make a lot
of sense and then there's this this is
the one that kind of hurts me a little
bit because i'm such a big fan of the
show and also of this um
of of this individual vince gilligan
who is the writer and creator of
breaking bad
has come out and according to the
reports anyway has accused
uh breaking bad fans of sexism
because of their treatment of one of the
characters on that show skyler who of
course is walter white's
wife
uh here's what it says a breaking bad
walter white played by brian cranston
builds a multi-million dollar meth
empire all while lying to his family and
mercilessly killing those who stand in
his way it was often his wife skyler
white played by anna gunn who was viewed
as the villain in the story in a lengthy
interview with the new yorker breaking
bad creator vince gilligan opened up
about the undeserved and often sexist
hatred towards skyler saying that it
troubled him and also the actor santa
gun now i will say that reading his
quotes he doesn't actually use the word
sexism he doesn't he doesn't
specifically say that but it does seem
to be what he's implying
he says back when the show first aired
skyler was roundly disliked i think that
always troubled anna gunn and i can tell
you it always troubled me because skyler
the character did nothing to deserve
that and anna certainly did nothing to
deserve that she played the part
beautifully i realized in hindsight that
the show was rigged in a sense that the
storytelling was solely through walt's
eyes even in scenes he wasn't present
for um
and so it was rigged and that's why
and then all the sexist fans came out
and he's he's upset about that and he
kind of regrets it
this makes no sense on a number of
levels
first of all i'm just trying to
understand you're accusing the show of
being rigged
well it was in a way it was written it
was scripted
by you you're one of the you you're the
creator of the show
so you wrote these characters and you
wrote her to be unlikable
fans are responding emotionally
to to the characters the way that you
wrote them
and yes the show is it's got to be
through someone's eyes it's pretty when
you have the central character of the
show for the show to be see for us to
sort of see the world through that
character's eyes that's
that's that's storytelling
that's what makes it interesting
that's why people like watching movies
and shows that's the kind of the point
of storytelling is to be able to you
know see the world through this
character's eyes
and now that makes you a sexist
it's also interesting because we're
always told
by the left that um you know art is
subjective they're always emphasizing
the subjective nature of art
and yet what we're constantly reminded
now is that actually well no it's not
subjective there are incorrect ways of
responding to works of art
and so many of the breaking bad fans
according to vince gilligan responded
incorrectly they were not supposed to
dislike this person
and if you don't like this actor's
portrayal of the character on the game
of thrones prequel that that's that's an
incorrect emotional response
ah so it turns out that art is objective
in the end
who would have thought let's get to the
comment section
[Music]
[Music]
we'll start with anna says matt we
haven't heard much about walrus gate
have you given up already did you let
the man win well i i don't i don't give
up on anything else i especially i'm not
going to give up on my giant walrus
especially because it's when it's in the
building somewhere how could i give up
on it um i have instead been
uh
running this down
behind the scenes investigating the
situation and what i'm what i'm starting
to understand more and more
over time is that this really is a
scandal which i didn't realize this at
first you know i thought i honestly
thought at first that this was just
you know miscommunication that's that's
all i thought was like no no one is
really responsible for it what i'm
starting to understand is that there
that there is
there's intention behind this and not
only that worse of all but the scandal
goes all the way to the top so what i've
what
here's just an example
it's come to my attention
that people have been
viewers have been sending walruses not
giant stuffed walruses but like smaller
little walruses to me i guess to you
know as kind of like a a consolation
prize to make me feel better i
appreciate it it's not it's not really
enough it's not you know it's not it's
not enough to make up for what's what
i've been deprived of but still
i appreciate it
and yet
um i obtained this photograph
from down in florida for apparently the
walruses that are supposed to be going
to me have been intercepted and are now
with ben down in florida so he has
not only taken away my giant walrus but
is also now taking the smaller walruses
away to
it's just things are getting very
strange
but i haven't given up i'll tell you
that joe blow says i had a vasectomy at
19. i truly regret that decision to this
day no one at that age has the proper
capacity to make those decisions
it's it is insane to me actually
that even at 19 uh they would that you
could go in at 19 and get a vasectomy
but well
because of course like at night you're a
19 year old guy and you at 19 you feel
like you're never going to want to have
kids
do you know how do you do you know
what what other 19 year old guys feel
that way like almost all of them
it's it's very common at 19 to think i
don't know when i was 19
i i couldn't ima i i hadn't i hadn't
signed off on the idea completely but i
couldn't imagine myself at 19 being a
father it was like an unimaginable thing
six years later i had two kids
and so going in even at 19 yes you're a
legal adult
but the doctors are performing
a procedure on you
and they must know that there's a high
likelihood that you're going to regret
it
and all the more so if it's a gender
transition surgery good thing about a
vasectomy by the way is that it can be
reversed right so you can actually
reverse that
a lot of these gender affirmation
surgeries or in fact all of them cannot
actually be reversed not completely
anyway
um
adam says
people are ignorant of the fact that
michael jackson's uh we're not going to
keep doing the michael jackson thing all
right fine uh michael jackson's bedroom
is two stories macaulay culkin is one of
the biggest defenders of michael and
that wade dobson's mother is a literal
con artist
but i'm not shocked when you take a man
with michael's appearance and his
childish behavior add in the media
repetition guys like matt take the bait
it was designed and sold to the
conservative audience for that reason
okay he i played the club for you he
said that he slept in bed with many
children he said that that's what he
said
not that he that he was in a two-story
bedroom slept in bed with many children
that's what he said so if you want to
continue to claim that that's a totally
normal thing and not suspicious at all i
know you don't believe that i know you
don't nobody does but if you feel like
you need to tell yourself that for some
reason then i i really i can't stop you
um
old timer says
and these activist pediatricians have
the power to report you to cps claiming
that you is are abusing your child by
not allowing pediatricians to transition
your child thus cps will take your child
away from you
that that's exactly right we've already
seen cases like that we've seen cases
like that in canada which it tends to be
even more egregious there because of the
way the laws are set up especially now
with their you know their laws the way
the laws against um
what do they call conversion therapy are
written in canada
it means that if you correctly gender
your child if you call your male child a
boy or a he
but he wants to be a she then you are
guilty of conversion therapy
that's abuse
like we heard from a father in what is a
woman which you can go to www.com and
watch that film now um and then you can
get your child taken away so that's
that's in canada but it's also it's
happening increasingly in this country
as well you're absolutely right about
that
um
let's see
dan says matt your wife getting a
college degree in sustaining student
debt did it pay off for her in a in a
rewarding career
genuinely curious considering your
stance as i fully agree with you
well
uh i i think she would agree with me
that it didn't exactly pay off because
she's not working in that field right
she's she's raising the kids i'm paying
off the debt um many such cases you know
here's the other thing
that's i think it's important point to
make about the student debt conversation
that i often criticize as many people do
the university system
for you know it's called edge for giving
a worthless education they get the
people get the degree they go out they
don't use it
um
but
in an ideal
scenario
we wouldn't be talking about using your
education like in an ideal
scenario an education would be
worthwhile for its own sake
so that if somebody went to school and
they got the degree they spent four
years in school or however many years
they got the degree
and they don't you know they end up
staying at home their stay-at-home mom
or whatever they or they work in a field
where degree is necessary ideally we'd
like to be able to say that well it
wasn't a waste because even though
they're not using the degree uh they
still got the education and so they're
they're just like a more well-rounded
more intelligent person and it's worth
it for its own sake so
they're not using education to make
money but they are using it in the sense
of it's it's part of them now right
um
so
i we should be able to say that but we
can't for a couple of reasons number one
it's so ridiculously expensive
it's too expensive to justify doing for
its own sake if you're gonna charge six
figures for something then it needs it
needs to have some practical application
you can't unless you're unless you're a
multi-millionaire you can't afford it
you can't justify
spending tens of thousands of dollars or
hundreds of thousands on an education
just for its own sake just for the
experience
and that's compounded by the fact
that um
the education that many that these
universities provide in so many cases
is worthless
in the sense that it's not going to help
you get a job but also in the sense that
it doesn't help you become a war welder
well-rounded person
a lot of these kids come out of college
and they're worse
and dumber than they were when they went
in
so that's another part of the
of the conversation we should be having
which is another reason why
we should be
focusing our criticism and ire on the
university system itself and and asking
it to account for itself
but we're not
or how about as others have suggested
here's a student loan forgiveness plan
that that i might actually be able to
get behind
make the universities pay it
take it from their endowments make them
pay it
okay you force harvard to to pay off the
loans for for all the uh harvard
graduates okay i could be i could get on
board with that
we're not gonna make harvard do we're
gonna make the plumber next door do it
recessions aren't recessions inflation
is good men are women if you're more
confused than usual lately it's by
design the left thinks they have a
monopoly on the definition of words and
they can silence you but they can't and
if you simply push back the house of
cards starts to collapse just look at
what in my film what is a woman my film
caused a rift in the space-time
continuum just because i asked a
question uh the month it came out the
daily wire had more members sign up than
at any other time in its history more
than 5 000 audience ratings on rotten
tomatoes later and the film still has
people talking people come up to me all
the time talking about it and that's a
good thing because the more we bring
these conversations out into the open
and the more we confront the madness the
sooner it will hopefully end so if you
haven't seen it yet go to what is a
woman.com and watch it now that's what
is a woman.com today now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
well you got to feel sorry for this
generation of kids for many reasons
really but especially because this is
the first generation of children who
will know what it's like to be raised by
social media influencers they're the
first to experience the trauma
of having their childhoods mind for
tick-tock content so take for example
the four-year-old daughter of tick-tock
influencer cat calamani whose social
rejection by the neighborhood kids was
immediately converted into content
by mommy
cat has made somehow headlines this week
after issuing a to use the new york post
phrase heartfelt plea to other parents
on the platform the post reports how a
tearful and devastated mother witnessed
her child being bullied and and
responded how any loving parent would by
leveraging the incident for internet
clout
so here is the emotional video which has
garnered over two million views by the
way which was totally not the point i'm
sure it was not the point of getting
views but uh here it is
parent and have kids
i need your help why is parenting so
hard my daughter's four and has these
little girls around her neighborhood who
i thought she got along great with well
i looked out the window and i saw
a couple of the girls putting their
hands out like they didn't want to play
with her and so i walked over there and
they were telling she's not allowed to
play with them because they didn't want
her to
she was devastated she was crying and
asking me why her friends don't like her
and why she can't play with them i
didn't even know how to respond i just
said
everyone sometimes makes mistakes and
sometimes people
aren't feeling the best and then they
treat other people not so nicely and you
can't control that
and when you are around people who are
not so nice
it's just best to walk away
because you can't control them
how do you handle situations like this
with your children
well not like that
she didn't know how to respond she
didn't know how so instead she took out
her phone
shot a selfie video
then edited it
and put sad piano music in the
background and then posted it and then
started furiously responding to the
supportive comments all while her
daughter presumably stood by sobbing
having now been ignored by both her
friends and her mom
but it's really it's the music which
does it for me that's that's what does
it it's you you
that's what destroys any chance that
this was like an authentic
i'm reaching out for help you're taking
the time to pick out the emotional music
to go along with it
no
now of course even apart from the clout
chasing the problem with the video is
that it's histrionic and absurdly
melodramatic it look it's really not a
big deal at all when little kids tell
other little kids that they don't want
to play with them that's how little kids
are they're quite fickle as a community
okay four-year-olds in particular are
prone to just like casually stabbing
each other in the back for no
discernible reason it's extremely common
for kids that age to play together
nicely for a while only for one to
suddenly run out of the room
and snitch on the other trying to get
him in trouble based on real or imagined
crimes and the amazing thing though is
that they can go right back to being
friends after that the betrayed child
doesn't hold anything against his
betrayer he doesn't even look at the
other kid and say what the hell dude i
thought we were cool what are you doing
no he he knows the rules and he accepts
them they all accept tattletailing as
inevitable it's it's a custom among
their people they all understand this
and the same goes for incidents like
what cat witnessed
a child will want nothing to do with
another child one minute only to be
pronouncing her a best friend the next
and in fact girls don't grow out of that
habit until like in their mid-70s
but the point is that kids experience
hurt feelings betrayals rejections all
the time
they'll be utterly devastated for 45
seconds and they forget about it
and you can even shorten that 45 second
period of sadness by giving them candy
or a sticker or a band-aid kids love
band-aids you can heal almost any wound
physical or emotional with a band-aid
and if it's a physical wound the
band-aid doesn't even have to be on the
part of their body that has the wound
the other day my my daughter had a small
cut on her on her hand but insisted that
we put a band-aid on her elbow
again these are the ways of childhood we
can never fully understand it even
though they were once our ways too
does this mean that we should never take
our children's emotions seriously no it
just means that we shouldn't blow things
out of proportion or create drama where
it's not necessary there's no need to
make mountains out of mole hills and we
especially should not be making
tick-tock videos out of them because
that is really the problem here you know
the world has always had mothers who get
far too emotional and upset about the
most minor pains or difficulties their
their children suffer i mean every good
mother has a tendency in that direction
to one degree or another that's why it's
important to have both a mother and a
father in the home
the mother has enough empathy to
compensate for the father's occasional
deficiencies in that regard and the
father has enough calmness and
rationality to compensate in the other
direction that's the complementary
nature of the sexes
saving the day yet again
but kat's problem is really not an over
abundance of empathy or emotion her
problem if anything is the opposite her
emotion is a performance for the camera
you know she saw her daughter's sadness
as a thing to be exploited a piece of
content for public consumption
she claims in the video that the
incident just happened a moment ago
which means that almost immediately the
thought occurred to her that the whole
thing would make a good tick tock video
it's not natural to think that way it
shouldn't be anyway
it's not surprising though when this
generation of parents my generation
views moments in life or really all of
life itself through this lens many of us
have been conditioned to put all of
ourselves out there for viewing making
spectacle of even the most banal moments
and experiences but not everything needs
to be presented to the public in this
manner and i say that as somebody whose
job necessitates talking into a camera
for over an hour every day
one of the reasons why we should retain
some semblance of a private life for
ourselves and especially for our
children is that the internet is not a
good substitute for a trusted confidant
or counselor
if you really feel that you need to vent
your frustrations or you need a shoulder
to cry on or you need some wisdom and
guidance
the comments section of tick tock is by
far and away the absolute worst place to
turn
faceless strangers who are scrolling
social media looking for content to
distract them from their own personal
lives are not suited for any of the
roles i just listed
they also don't know you or care about
you
and they will have forgotten about what
you posted five seconds after they see
it
but the bigger problem is that when you
when you get into the habit
of packaging your life into these
bite-sized videos and social media posts
and offering them up as pieces of
entertainment for strangers who will
then in return give you a rating through
likes and shares which you will
obsessively track and count
when you do all that and you do it every
day for years as so many people do
after a while you begin to lose the
ability to live your life as a normal
human being you forfeit your humanity to
a large extent you begin to think about
all of your experiences in terms of how
many likes they can get you start
engineering things in your life so
they'll be better fodder for an
influencer post
you live your life with your back turn
to it looking at it through your phone
with your face in the foreground and
everything else blurred into the
background
we now have multiple generations of
americans who live this way constantly
sacrificing authenticity
for the sake of making content
until they no longer know how to live
authentically
so cat calamani is far from alone
but she is the one who is today
unfortunately cancelled
and that will do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block if you're not a member once again
go to dailywire.com become a member and
you can watch the whole entire show
otherwise
we'll talk to you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you